la première édition de playboy avec
marilyn monroe provoque et bouscule les
moeurs de l'amérique sont fondateurs
disaient alors publier un magazine pour
se faire plaisir
les éditions suivantes lui ont plutôt
permis de se bâtir un empire un magazine
dont le tirage atteint 7 millions
d'exemplaires en novembre 1972
aujourd'hui avec un tirage d'à peine
huit cent mille copies playboy annonce
virage finie la nudité
les femmes seront toujours présenté
comme un objet de convoitise dans des
poses provocantes mais sans jamais se
dévêtir complètement à l'ère du web de
la porno gratuite et facile d'accès la
direction d'entreprises cherchent une
façon de se distinguer et d'aller
chercher un auditoire plus jeunes en
entrevue au new york times l'actuel
éditeurs dit vouloir renouveler
l'auditoire en offrant un contenu qui
s'apparente à celui de vice et oui on
veut vous vendre playboy également pour
les articles mais en abandonnant la
nudité playboy pourra surtout rendre son
contenu accessible au partage sur les
réseaux sociaux comme facebook
une façon d'assurer la visibilité de la
marque une marque et des produits
dérivés aujourd'hui bien plus rentable
que le magazine la preuve selon le new
york times playboy tirs 40% de ses
revenus en chine et les chinois n'ont
même pas accès au magazine ici récents
maisonneuve radio canada montréal
m